so there's
obviously something going on in the
bigger picture whether definitely
i've heard we are our technology right
now is like 400 years ahead of everybody
else
so you look at like david what do you
mean everybody else like the rest of the
world
the rest of the world america's
technology is 400 years ahead of what
technology
any gravity okay i never even heard of
anti-gravity until this year
until bob lazar nope bob azar didn't
bring it up
no uh he talked about anti-gravity but
nobody ever said we have anti-gravity
that's here and working and we're
dealing with it now
that whole with david flavor with that
tic-tac yep they say that was ours
we're doing it some people say that yeah
well the group that just came out
said that's ours we're going to go into
we're going to comp but again
which group i don't know through the us
pentagon
it was the pentagon pentagon said that
that was ours that was ours it's all
none of it's easy no no there was a no
no i think it was the new york times
article just came out two weeks ago it
said that
the the headline of the new york times
article was um
there's no evidence that this is alien
correct
but it also didn't say they said they
don't know what it is they came out and
said it was ours
well is it really ours who's it really
saying that but at the end of the day
they're definitely saying it wasn't
an extraterrestrial but they also said
the new york times article also said
they didn't know what it was
right but now all of a sudden there's
more photos of it coming up some other
girls now have actually videotaped it
from they were staying on the ground
videotaping it so this is a new video
taping the tic tac
yeah where flying between some mountains
she's like what is that i don't know
what it is but you look at it you go
like that's the same you see this i was
on tv about two weeks ago
david favorite you say now that looks at
the same thing that favor saw that day
that he was flying the plane
and she's going you know flying right
through the mountains and just
buzzing along is there a video of this
oh yeah the girl that took it she
didn't know what it was now nobody said
in the show that was the tic tac but
when you look at you're like dude that's
round it's long it looks just like what
he was talking about there's no flying
no wings
and like i said there's just so much
information coming out
that it's hard to stay you know up on it
and stay
you know where you need to be is that
right it's like a full-time job
yeah oh it's definitely a full-time job
well because listen to you there's a lot
of fake stuff going on i mean they were
talking about now about drones
and numbers that are going up in the air
they had uh they just recorded
14 ufos around a navy ship
um about a month ago the navy still
doesn't know what they were but they
were all over the ship
yeah no no yeah yeah i saw that so yeah
on the radar
or on the you know again was that us was
it not us you know is it
are they trying to do that to see what
you know how these guys are gonna
respond to it from a military
perspective
um i don't know my favorite out of all
of the recorded encounters i mean like
the the abduction stories are crazy with
uh
with um betty those are good yeah betty
and
get abducted yeah you just see what it's
like god won it betty have you heard
the betty and barney white story or the
betty and barney hill
and then who was the other guy uh who's
the dude the who
we were talking about the other day yeah
there's a couple there's a couple guys
the guy who was in arizona who got
abducted
um we were talking about it in the last
podcast anyways
but out of all of them my favorite one
is the zimbabwe
story because there's like 25 people
who all have the same exact story
there's more than 25 actually like
half the school saw it yeah so in the
90s like 1993
or something a a spaceship landed in a
pl
in a field outside of a school in
zimbabwe
allegedly all 20 of the kids so we don't
get shut up they just like walk out and
just like it's just
there allegedly thank you shadow man
here's what they did they actually went
back to the school and they brought back
all the kids
there the story is [ __ ] bonkers
because they had they got
a psychiatrist came and interviewed all
the kids and they were all
like between the ages of like five and
ten or something and they had
pictures and a psychiatrist had them all
draw pictures and talk about
individually
individually right separate from each
other and
all the kids had the same exact [ __ ]
story how these little creatures
childlike
figures came out of this space this
saucer
and stood there and they were like
within 10 feet of them
and they all or a couple of them that
were closest to the aliens
they said that they had these like
visions in their head
of like technology is bad technology is
going to be like the downfall of the
human race
and there was no like verbal talk but
they all like
had these thoughts of like how
technology is bad and they thought
like now they're discovering it they
were just they just there's this
documentary just put out where they
interviewed them now and they're all
like in their 30s 40s
and um and they're all like
you know recalling what happened back
then and the story hasn't changed after
all this time the story hasn't changed
at all yet because
they interviewed all the kids back back
in the 90s and they just interviewed him
again just now
and they all like have been thinking
about it ever since and they believed
that it was just
you know the aliens telepathically
communicating with the kids
thinking that they could get the message
across to humanity that
whatever well those aliens need to
practice what they preach if they're
using crazy technology that's what i
thought
a bunch of hypocrites they are but maybe
ours is going to destroy us
terminator whatever everything's going
to kill you how are you going to how are
you going to come down in some crazy
anti-gravity
in some crazy anti-gravity spaceship
travel thousands of light years
like you know what technology sucks
don't use it yeah well here's the
interesting thing
one of the guys now oh yeah right well
one of the guys that i was talking to
and he was we were talking about this
whole thing because we i don't think
they're flying millions of miles i think
they're here
but i also think with these portals and
he said you know if you think about
you just think if you were a fish you
were in the water
you were looking up and i took my boat
and set my boat in the water
now you can see the bottom of my boat
from from the fish's perspective oh yeah
look at that
because if i pick that boat up in your
mind's eye that boat just disappeared
so now i bring that boat over here and
sit down over here you're like check
that out
how did it get over there now so you go
so what's ever on the other side of
reality
is that you go so these things are
moving around and sort of that same
ideology right he goes but they're here
they've been here all along they're not
traveling millions of miles there's more
dimensions they can travel in different
forms of matter that we probably can't
even see
right like like water air sure time
gravity well they just showed that one
of the interesting things was this this
pilot in
um alaska said he's been there for 40
years
because i've never seen anything like
this that a volcano erupt and he goes so
i'm flying some customers out to a to a
place where they're going to be
uh hunting and he goes i look over the
volcano and he goes we've kind of been
we're getting a big path because they've
been put puffing out some smoke
and he goes but something in a cloud
that was a that was trying to hide in
the cloud but was doing a terrible job
but you could see it
like a fat guy trying to hide behind a
tree that's exactly it so he started
taking pictures of it
until it went into the volcano and then
later
he said about five minutes after that
happened this big green orb came out of
it he took pictures of this green orb he
goes
listen i'm not saying they're ufos i
don't know what they are but whatever
was going on was going on it was
definitely a for sure
so i think the orbs um just like we saw
because they're seeing more identical to
what we saw
that day uh on other tv shows now with
drones so whatever the drone is able to
do whether the drone is making a noise
it likes to hear
because all these things that one that
you took the video of
changed directions and came up towards
that remember you thought hey someone's
shooting at my drone yeah and even when
i was watching this somebody said that i
laughed
um because this whatever the first one
came by close and the second one like
dude came by it real close right and i
just refer to them as dirty cotton balls
but i think those whatever they are is
that's part of the earth man the earth
is a living entity and they are
here protecting the earth whatever they
are
um because they seem to be always
i've got i'm trying to get this from
tyler i took a video
about four years ago of this thing it
was night it was uh
uh in the wintertime very cool out and
the sky was crystal clear
and there was this ball of light and it
was literally looked like if you had a
laser and you were just kind of waving
it around
and i'm like what the hell is that so
the one thing that i noticed if i took
my camera out and i tried to follow it
what i noticed was if i took that camera
and held it like on a planet and i moved
it
it looked the light was moving and i was
moving actually moving the camera so
that's not gonna work
so i had to position the camera to get
this thing to fly through it
so that you could actually see it right
and i managed to do that
so whatever this thing is and it was
funny i had the feeling like
it's having a good time it's fun it's
like it's playing in the in the wind
whatever this thing was but that's what
i feel these things are now
the the extraterrestrials that are
coming here if you go back and start
looking at the anunnaki
and you start really looking at the
anunnaki hard
they talk about they took us as humans
because the anunnaki and the sumerians
didn't want to be
mining all this gold they ate gold back
then
because they said listen our bodies are
electric by eating gold man it just
absolutely makes your body the most uh
perfect
you know the way your the system
operates just absolutely perfect
that's what i tell myself when i drink a
bottle of gold
it's like gold slugger doing it baby so
he said so expensive
so when they when they would do that he
said they decided they didn't want to
dig for this goal anymore so they
started breeding with us
and because what they did was they
changed the dna and they made it so that
we thought about nothing but gold
we really haven't changed a whole lot we
still think about gold today
so more so about bitcoin definitely
about bitcoin
where's that going right now anyway down
and up down up there
i